Rein in die Pedale
und rauf auf den Pop-up-Radweg:
Diese neuen gelb markierten Fahrradstreifen
haben in Berlin einiges
in Bewegung gebracht.
Sie wurden eilig
in der Corona-Pandemie geschaffen,
um Fahrradfahrern mehr Platz
und Sicherheit zu bieten.
Für Nik Kaestner ist das aber nicht genug:
Er träumt von einer Innenstadt
ganz ohne privaten Autoverkehr
und sammelt Unterschriften
für ein Volksbegehren.
Ja, wir wünschen uns auch,
dass die Stadt klimafreundlicher wird.
Und die Klimaziele erreichen wir nicht,
wenn wir weiterhin mit Autos rumfahren.
Und sogar mit E-Autos
erreichen wir nicht unsere Ziele,
denn E-Autos können auch Unfälle bauen
und nehmen trotzdem viel Platz weg.
Sein Ziel: genug Unterschriften
zusammenzubekommen,
damit die Berliner am Tag
der Bundestagswahl im September
auch darüber abstimmen,
ob sie Autos aus der Innenstadt
verbannen wollen.
Und wie sieht das die Politik?
Zu einem Termin mit der
Berliner Verkehrssenatorin
bin ich wieder auf einem
neuen Radweg unterwegs.
300 Parkplätze für Autos wurden hier
vor Kurzem abgeschafft.
Und die grüne Verkehrssenatorin
will die Mobilitätswende in Berlin
noch weiter voranbringen.
Dass wir erst mal
die Angebote deutlich ausweiten:
also mehr ÖPNV,
eine bessere Radinfrastruktur,
eine bessere Verkehrsinfrastruktur
auch für die Fußgängerinnen.
Und dass wir dann
sehr wahrscheinlich auch den Preis
für den öffentlichen Raum verteuern.
100 Kilometer Schnellradwege sind geplant,
um die Berliner Innenstadt demnächst
besser mit den Außenbezirken zu verbinden.
Der Mobilitätsforscher Andreas Knie
besitzt kein Fahrrad und kein Auto.
Er bucht Bahnfahrten,
Autos und Fahrräder mit dem Handy
und fordert eine radikale Share-Strategie.
Nur geteilte Mobilität stoppe
den Flächenverbrauch, so sein Credo.
Wir werden viel mehr mobile Arbeit haben
und wir werden lernen,
auch in ländlichen Räumen
die Autos zu teilen.
Das wird nicht so
das klassische Carsharing sein.
Sondern wenn man alleine unterwegs ist,
macht das keinen Sinn,
wenn fünf Menschen mit fünf Autos
zur selben Zeit in dieselbe Richtung fahren,
sondern [dann] fahren eben
fünf Menschen in einem Auto.
Das kann man mit
digitalen Plattformen wunderbar machen,
und so können wir auch auf dem Land
die Anzahl der Autos drastisch reduzieren.
Wie sind wir in Zukunft unterwegs?
Die Mobilitätswende weg vom Auto
hat gerade erst begonnen.